What will happen. The Joe Rogan
experience. I love what Jon Anik said too.
He loves when he fights cause then
Bruce buffer has to say, your boy,
boy,
boy.
Hey, why does it, where
does keep a suits man?
He's got a new suit is a
bad mother fucker dude.
The insides of always has
like different decorations.
Shit come ever eight different places
where we're at. Bruce Buffer, he's,
he's got style. I just imagined him
have a level on his house just, Oh yeah,
I'm all, you know what I mean? Like
you go do it Nordstrom or something,
but his is just all the suits. That
was Warren before. I mean I'm less,
he donated so he might
donate them to charity now.
That might be one of the art auction
them for charity or something like that.
That'd be good. Yeah.
He's a, he's a fun dude.
He's the best ring announcer
of all time to men.
When that guy starts wailing and
he gets so pumped up, seriously,
this is fucking hurt. Gets right.
It's like he's so intense, man.
I give you watched boxing,
they're much more smoothly. Yeah.
Bruce buffer gets into
it, man. He digs in.
I remember seeing him first yell at like
at Tj Dillashaw and he was like, oh.
I was like, Oh shit. It gives
you goosebumps. It really does.
It gives you goosebumps. Yeah. You just
feel the energy, right? You're just like,
I'm there waiting, ready for a
fight. Look, I'm kind of nervous.
And then Bruce comes over like, yeah,
out of the blue corner. You're like,
all right.
Talking about dude who blew his ACL out
from jumping up in the rear while he was
reading his name. Oh my God. 10
gets bruised here at tough duty.
Okay.